we put this place together we thought
about having good energy good food good
vibes representing the community city
and giving jobs matter of fact let's go
have lunch come on we're playing over
here this is finger licking man we got
the last of the shrimp we got the steak
we got the rice we got the red velvet
what's this coffee pot seafood rice rule
of real laughs of collard greens it's
real up in here boy the energy in here
is family fun the community tourists
everybody come to finger-licking mind
the garden let's see the file personal
listen I don't know who God Fieri is
right I notice respect alone at all but
we have the best chefs in the world this
is like real home cooking Miami style
soul food Miami style I love the
meatloaf I love the lobster another
chicken wings and I love the red velvet
cake red velvet cake
first thing the litter in North Miami
been open for a year and the minute that
was open I immediately was on the
franchise the next room when I got with
each class I partner up with him and I
was like this is the only big man I love
the food I love the energy and that's
family so we join forces together to
plan an openness as many as we can but
we want to take our time because we care
about our city and make sure they love
it and I feel like it's gonna be like
something they're gonna talk about 100
years from now the energy has always
been good but it's just it's exciting
they're excited for the kids we do
community events back to school events
we're gonna do concerts which we just
sing here Bob there's a good places to
network we're just trying to reach a
different audience and you know provide
good food to the community and your
family whether you don't have to go to
South Beach you don't have to go to
haven't sure you can just come in the
hood and go forward area means a lot to
me Carol City Miami Gardens and I'll
never forget that so when I come here
and eat lunch every day I see the same
people I seen 27 years ago plus new
people and they see me all the time cuz
I'm from the crib and now coming to
Miami cutting my restaurant
finger making the Miami Gardens Carol
City and Steve Wynn